uh
yikes that was a bit of a a bomb to drop
on this note but um
i'm gonna cry
[Music]
let's see this one's real folded
oh this one's long oh
they said what if you get a sad one and
i sure did um
i kept my dad's alcoholism a secret for
years and he used to tell me how he
never wanted a child like me
and how i would never find love flash
forward a few years and my first
boyfriend said i would never find love
either so now i don't feel worthy of
love and won't date because i feel too
broken
i'm going to cry they know my friends
who are with me know that i cry like at
everything
i cry when i talk i cry when other
people cry so like
that was so sad i hope that that person
finds love and realizes that they're
worthy of it even if it's through like
friendships i mean that's what's been
most important to me is finding i
like friends who who appreciate
all the sides of me so i can only hope
that for that person and if i knew them
i would give them all the love
that i could um damn
my turn my turn i was gonna write
something something funny i'm like
okay
oh so stupid whoever reads this i hope
they i hope they get a good laugh out of
it
i'm not always as brave as i may seem
i i feel that
the moment i read it i was like yeah
me too i wish i was divorced
my wife has made me feel trapped for six
years
i didn't know i was pregnant until i
miscarried
i feel guilty because i may have had
something to do with it
the night before i found out i was drunk
i've stabbed the person three times
without
any remorse and i wonder if that makes
me inhumane
i wanted a happy one
i slept with my teacher and he still
didn't give me a good grade
i don't know just say
i can't tell if i should go after the
hot i mean hot
boy or my best friend who i can see
something stronger
happen okay
that is horribly relevant to mine like i
always like
get friend zoned by people yeah
but i'm also like the hot girl you know
what i mean
[Laughter]
i think you gotta go for the long
lasting one
you gotta go for the for the for the
best friend not the boy
who's hot exclamation point h-a-w-t
exclamation point
so i would maybe like go for the hot boy
first and then
i was gonna say don't tell a friend
that's really bad don't do that no
um moral compass go for the go for the
friend
[Laughter]
my parents don't know that i got an scd
and that i am no longer a virgin
oh i uh i can really relate with this
person
not the std part but um just the not
having that uh
bond with the parents being able to talk
to them about certain things
i totally understand how this person
feels and where they're coming from and
missing that connection with their
parents i think it's something special
that
everybody should have but not everybody
does
i feel like i can relate to this okay
um this person's secret is i feel like
i'm never satisfied in life and always
wanting more
i guess because like i have a really
hard like self-critic so i'm always like
i want more like i want to be the best
and i feel like i may never like
reach that stuff so i guess also
i guess that could be my secret too
whereas i can relate to this person
i was sexually assaulted when i was 14
years old
and i've never been able to talk to a
boy with confidence and trust ever again
i was uh assaulted
at a younger age too and
uh um
it's a hard burden to carry because
sometimes
you don't know if you're carrying it at
all and you just
develop into your personality
loss of trust of the people around you
and
fear of the unknown so i understand it
secrets hold a lot of weight and uh
when uh you can focus and distract
yourself from
the weight you're carrying you can i
mean personally i can go about my day
but when i have to confront um secrets
that i'm holding
[Music]
i lose my resilience uh enough to uh
come close to uh breaking down or crying
and since i'm in public i'm trying to uh
contain myself a little bit but it's
late in the day and
i'm kind of a little bit more relaxed
than i usually am so uh
i'm emotional enough to just like maybe
my eyes are getting watery so i just
um can't wait to go back to ignoring
this secret
sometimes i fall into a complete spiral
to a point where i'll never get out
at times huh
that's way deeper than i thought it
would be just for the person that
wrote this i mean if you ever like at
the bottom the only way is up right
there's no other way i'm scared that the
real me
is someone who is not as good as i want
to be
meaning i get jealous and manipulate
i still have feelings for my ex i wish i
never got married
it says i need to eat more vegetables
i like owen i don't know who owen is but
you are very lucky
alright so the secret is i ruined my
cousin's bridesmaid dress
before the wedding and never told her
one time i accidentally peed
my pants in the freezer at work
um i really want like a follow up as to
what happened
and if anybody found out i lick my own
pack
i think that's awesome
i don't love my boyfriend anymore and i
don't know how to tell him
i think to leave him a note and then
ghost him
on halloween of 2019 while dressed in
full
cowgirl attire i peed in between two
subway cars
because my train was stuck and then i
peed on the steps of this
the train station oops lol
um i don't know i probably
would have done the same thing honestly
my boyfriend
cheated on me with a married man
hold on let me my boyfriend cheated on
me with a married man
that's tea i've been dating a boy
for four years now i've found out
recently that
i'm lesbian i don't know how to tell him
whoever you are that you just found out
i think you should just come out and
tell them all right guys
i'm gonna read one it's kind of dead out
here no one's stopping so
and no i did not put my secret in here
so don't try to guess
okay it says i worry about whether or
not my brother
is capable of harming his significant
other out of rage
so the first thing i thought after i
read this
was that i felt bad for whoever wrote it
because it makes me feel like they
probably have some experience with their
brother being harmful towards them
which is why they have this fear so i
hope that's not true
i hope they've never experienced
anything like that but it's really sad
because it seems like that's the case so
sending lots of love to them i am an
insult
and it's not that i'm bitter or mean but
it's because i see the big picture
modern women are entitled and men are
the ones who have to take
the brunt like gain their trust for
example
i do disagree i think this person has
been hurt
if they think like that especially about
like towards all women
because i know a lot of women who are
you know great and amazing
i wish i could let myself trust the
people i love
more yeah
i relate to that honestly i was honestly
gonna put the same thing
on there too the failure of
relationships in my family have
caused me to question if it will ever be
possible for me
to be loved by someone else
my parents marriage is the reason i
don't want to get married
everything i do is overcompensate for
validation
it's about how i look i think the best
thing i would give someone like the
person who wrote this
is just to spend more time with
themselves
and just be comfortable with who they
are
and once you have that like
comfort and love for yourself you don't
really start to seek for that validation
how i did it like what i think is the
best is just
to go out like on dates with yourself or
like
treat yourself like after you get your
paycheck go get something that you
really wanted
and just show that love that you seek
for
from others like give it to yourself and
don't wait for it
so i think that's what everybody should
be doing
and then you start to attract the energy
that you you become
instead of chasing it and seeking for it
all right guys it's getting kind of late
and i'm gonna go home soon so
i thought i'd read the remaining secrets
in this bowl
all right first secret i'm annoyingly in
love with my best friend but can never
do anything
about it damn
you should call them up and ask them on
a date
and it's that easy i'm just kidding i
know it's not that easy
all right next one i've told my
alcoholic dad
that i've forgiven him for all the pain
he has caused me
i haven't and i'm not sure
i ever will
um
looks like there's two of us who have
forgiveness problems
whether you do ever forgive them or if
you don't
i hope that the pain goes away
yeah thanks for sharing this alright
guys that's all the secrets in the bowl
um
thanks for watching this episode i know
it was new i hope you enjoyed it
and yeah it's my birthday at the end of
this month and i don't know why
this birthday has to be feeling
a certain type of way and it's like in a
good way the best way i could describe
the way this birthday is making me feel
is that it's the way i felt right before
my birthday right before i started this
channel
it's making me want to try a lot of new
things
which means you'll be seeing a lot of
new content on my channel
but also still the old content as well
don't worry i'll keep sharing those but
you'll see i have some things planned
and it's going to start showing so
yeah i hope you stay tuned i hope you
enjoy thank you guys for everything
i love you all and i'll see you next
week